welcome to this video and I got a big
one here this is Hikaru Nakamura okay
always can they look forward to such a
game let's see what happens I was seeing
that he was is not playing here okay now
he is let's see what we get
playing a solid opening nothing nothing
crazy Queen some Queen's Indian type of
information okay hmm yeah can go d4 I
can also just take which should be quite
okay for me with the with a better
development it looks like a variation
where he soloist like like a chemical
down but okay he is playing all kinds of
openings and in blitz let's see mmm ship
g5 maybe it's a good chemical move here
Bishop e7 I can take and take on c5
which is certainly a little bit better
forward yeah this is something that he
probably does not like to play a lot mmm
take it take here I mean this looks this
looks dangerous for black let's think
about it is a form may be a key for
ticks and I'm flushing his King out
there
Queen a4 also might be an idea and
tending and this is maybe easier but the
idea to play you for a for trapping is
Bishop okay
so I can't play you for now
okay if I think about this for for ten
minutes I will lose on time and so I'm
going for that let's see
rook e1 hook d1 those kind of moves you
can also just take g5 and ask him where
are you going to castle I mean it's not
going to Castle short probably and
longer I mean looks looks very fishy
this is just great for what to be
perfectly honest look you won or what
why not
so Queen h4 yes Queen f5 as well and if
I take e seven now what does this reply
actually Queen is several [ __ ] h4 isn't
this isn't this a disaster am i winning
this game this would be funny black yes
I got it
Wow I got it okay really adding off an
off game here but you don't I have like
a scarf I don't know 3 out of 100
against him so okay let me just
celebrate in a little bit here don't get
this kind of scalp very often whoo yeah
he really he really played them I really
played a bad opening here some somehow
this is this is I think already a bit
fishy because he he really has problems
in the center I'm just much better
developed and I don't know I mean
I is writing to me if you want to take
this like at the World Championship
match fine
that doesn't count for anything though
yeah sure it just splits let melet me
have my fun do what you win but let me
have a little bit of let me let that may
have a little bit of fun yeah you beat
me like a hundred games you bt 97 times
so it's just nice to have one winning
okay and yeah 'if is already quite good
here and now it writes to me and you
have the arrogance to start making moves
on the board afterwards no I'm not
arrogant I'm just looking at the game a
little bit I really don't understand why
it's a little bit more why it's not a
little bit more relaxed about things
he's a world-class player and should be
really relaxed about it okay
yeah and around here it gets it gets
difficult after you fall like now is in
trouble and I mean you can can argue
about things rook t1 seems to be good
and yeah but this is this is just
winning so I think I did it did an okay
job it's he of course um had a really
really bad opening yeah okay I guess a
little bit of celebrating is so is in
order sometimes okay I hope you enjoyed
it thanks for watching